as it's Rasmus dolene who will carry it down
into the penguin Zone and his shot will go to
the far board Skinner waiting on it Russ tips
it ahead to Crosby he finds o coner he had two
in the last game against these two and he scores
quickly here 20 seconds in oh you're right d he
scored a couple in Pittsburgh 20 seconds he's
going to capitalize stand up right there clip
gets caught a little bit not getting back it's
not his fault right here along the wall this is
it comes out this is where the problem happens
you got Doan caught Clifton pulls back he tries
his best to get back there and do what he can do
but a perfectly placed [Applause] shot up towards
center before the Sabers defenseman fires it
in here's a turn over jar and now in front
Second Chance scores Victor ol in at a couple of
stabs at it the second one counts since tie to
one here's J little nonchalant here on this play
and the good pressure there in the corner and that
is JJ pety he's going to get in right on top
of him right here pick this one off but the
where about soon as he gets it turns and looks
for somebody coming in and Victor Olsen he gets
a couple waack at it finally able to put it in
the back of the net but that's the kind of goal
you got to get to settle this game down a little
bit and even it out second man is supposed to be
going to that far post anyways there's going
to be somebody to possibly pick up that puck
here's a race for the puck in the Buffalo Zone
and a shot off the bar by Neo going glove side
again on Devin Levi Yoki Haru trying to turn it
right back in Thompson gets back onside working
on rule Skinner is with him takes the pass
Benson wide open what timer sto by [Applause]
jar face off coming up here for this second
period Tage Thompson and Sydney Crosby Bonnet
to Bonnet Sabers from right to left and away we
go L Tang sends ac across ice and Crosby will
tip it down towards Levi above the goal line
too the Penguins lifted back into the Buffalo
zone two minutes gone here second period tie
game at one middle step for Greenway Benson
scores it's a pre season Zack attack and
the Sabers have taken a two to one lead
just watch nine he finds his way and gets in
the H he doesn't get in a big hurry and gets
himself overplayed he just takes his time very
good patience and right here he knows this P's
going to have a good chance coming to him he's
going to get separation he's going to get away
from the D he reaches out for that Puck and
able to put it past Jerry but what a great
pass by Greenway right there to find opening
it up is power sending it over to that first
Circle olison middle stat you've got pet
in the bumper right now here it is scores
PKA power play goal and the Sabers take a 3
to1 lead here in the second [Music] period
let's watch here they do a good job as I said
just moving the puck around the perimeter right
here just waiting for something to happen look
at all the movement here within the penalty
Killers once they get down here everybody kind
of comes over to this one side everybody's in
the middle they start coming down lower and
lower petka does a nice job just maintaining
that position even when the puck goes down to
the net he doesn't drive to the net he stays
back knowing that if there is a rebound this
is where it's coming and that's exactly what
happened hit his stick bang he let it go with
1256 to go in Period number two shot stopped by
Jerry but there is a rebound there it's picked
up by malan he'll start the Penguins back Riley
Smith good passing here by Pittsburgh and they
have got themselves within a goal it's three to2
now see everybody just everybody's on top of
everything everybody's covered they took the
middle of the ice away contested there just a
quick drop pass and Clifton putting pressure on
his man everything's good here this shot just goes
far as side first time we saw him in preseason it
looked like a first preseason game we talk about
veteran guys older guys have been around they know
what they got to get to do yeah there's a oh the
net was knocked off it went in the net yeah refer
on top of that as soon as as soon as the puck hit
the back of the net that 44 ref he was making sure
there was nothing so who knocked who into who that
knocked the net off here's a look oh that would be
clipon throwing an Eller into the net we're going
to have a goal here I think yeah I think they
are Pittsburg player was pushed in by a
buffalo player therefore we have
a good goal here's joose testing
jari Sabers with a good answer so far but
the Penguins with a potential
three on two here pushing in
scores driving the net that time o Conor and
the Penguins certainly have turned the corner
here they all of a sudden have a 4-3 Lead
watch this it's it's a three on two Joe gets
back right here trying to do his best and it
looks like doing directed him across to take
yeah he does he directs him over to take the
puck carrier and doin's looking to take that
pass away the other Pittsburgh player pulls up
Ellers that's in the high slot area play that
one away from Malon is trying to take it free
KB's got a stick on it malan plays it back to
Carlson he'll set it up shot tipped in by
Malin 5-3 Penguins now malcin finish this
off but what a pass by Carlson from the point
as soon as this puck gets to the point he's
looking his heads up from Carlson to malcol for
the redirect watch this he's looking at him the
whole way look at the Lane right there that lane
opened up he had two Sabers stacked on this side
but nobody's stick on the right side and it
left that lane wide open and malcol the big
man over in The Far Side there just redirects
it pass not only at the end of last year and
during last year but so far in preseason that
uh two goals is nothing so here we go Sabers
from left to right in this third period and the
Penguins get a first touch but quickly taken away
by Tage Thompson he'll played onto the wing for
Skinner quick shot to test jari now Benson will
play it for power Puck bounced on him a little
bit reading that is Pon so he jumped on it in a
hurry and Carter looking to cut to the net with
a quick shot that one off the leg in front they
score well the Penguins run of goals continue
here as they get down low in front of the
Sabers [Applause] goal here's the first Puck goes
to the front there's the shot and Carter on the
second opportunity misses on the forehand but
catches it on the backand and there's the first
one going he loses it right there and then on
the back hand standing beside Benson right now
the Sabers trying to take care of business here
in this third period still plenty of time 1328
remaining down six to three here's a chance in
front of the net with the backand scor Casey
Middle St with a dart to get the Sabers within
a [Applause] [Music] pair 64 Penguins to Casey
middle stats what you expect out of them right
here ni a little l pass up Benson doing a nice
job getting a hold of this one and getting it
back to Middle stat and you see him driving in
the net there see if this Puck Benson makes
a great play here just feeding him and right
there middle step drifts to the left Circle the
Tang out front for the one-time and Crosby of the
far post had a stab at it Crosby again out front
and they bury that one Chris lat Tang from Sydney
Crosby with four 47 to go in the third 7even
to four Penguins Far Side there he is sneaks
right down and he's going to get this one timer
from the feed from Crosby in the corner there's
Crosby just makes a nice play pushing it back
out to the de comes back down to Crosby and he
finds Crystal and of course don't forget the 50/50
guaranteed jackpot that night as well so a lot to
look forward to for the Sabers they come out on
the wrong end of a seven four final here tonight